[Musica]
a posto allora siamo forse nel luogo più
adatto a parlare stiamo forse nel luogo
più adatto parlare di rinascita
rinascimenti perché questo luogo che
rappresenta il nostro salone in realtà è
stato protagonista di una grande
rinascita la rinascita della città di
padova all'inizio del 200 come il luogo
essenziale di un'università la prima
grande università libera è stato il
luogo affrescato da giotto che rinasce
dopo che gli affreschi di giotto vanno
perduti adesso lo vedete nel suo facies
quattrocentesca perché quando parliamo
di rinascimento dobbiamo immaginare che
ogni epoca ha avuto un suo rinascimento
guardate ad esempio questo parco è il
parco che tutti riconosciamo stiamo a
roma a villa borghese al centro di
questo parco c'è la galleria borghese
la galleria borghese che rappresenta
forse il più bel museo del mondo un
museo ammantato delle opere di gian
lorenzo bernini questo meraviglioso
ratto di proserpina in cui guardate come
bernini rende morbido il marmo oppure la
pollo e dafne una d'arte che si tramuta
immediatamente nel momento in cui viene
ghermita da pollo o tutta la forza e la
potenza dello sguardo di un david mentre
sta per scagliare la sua pietra le opere
raccolte volute dal cardinal nipote da
scipione borghese quello scipione
borghese che non aveva neanche essere
fermato davanti a nulla per rubare opere
e costruire una collezione che diventerà
la più bella collezione del mondo oggi
la collezione italiana perché la
galleria borghese oggi è pubblica ed è
pubblica dal 1880 dalla fine
dell'ottocento quando il crac della
famiglia borghese fasti che lo stato
italiano possa acquisirla
ma per acquisirla bisogna stabilire un
valore alle opere che sono al suo
interno
allora pensate cosa c'è all'interno
della borghese c'è il principe di
pittorici tiziano tiziano esegue questo
amor sacro amor profano che viene
valutato dai grandi storici all'arte che
fanno le stime 2 milioni di lire
però la galleria borghese anche uno dei
grandi furti di scipione borghese cioè
la deposizione di cristo di raffaello
per noi raffaello pare veramente molto
più di un tiziano eppure al tempo nel
1888 arriva un milione di lire e nella
galleria borghese però c'è anche
un'altra opera un'opera di correggio
quel correggio che forse oggi in mano ai
più sconosciuto ebbene questa immagine
viene valutata un milione esattamente
tanto quanto raffaello ma la borghese
anche i grandi capolavori di caravaggio
tutti avete visto tutti conoscete questo
meraviglioso fanciullo concesso di
frutta questo cesto di frutta che
rappresenta per noi un icona varrà di
più o meno tiziano raffaello e correggio
allora il tempo valeva 100 lire non
voleva assolutamente nulla era poco più
che legna da ardere perché alla fine
dell'ottocento caravaggio era un signore
tutto deve scoprire lo scopriremo alla
metà del novecento allora in questo
momento interviene il barone roskilde il
grande banchiere americano che dice allo
stato italiano
caro stato italiano siete un po come
diremmo oggi con le pezze al culo siete
appena nati
allora io faccio una cosa
vi offro 4 milioni di lire con 4 milioni
mi porta a casa solo un'opera l'amor
sacro amor profano egiziano il resto ve
lo tenete considerate che la galleria
borghese verrà acquistata per 3 milioni
e mezzo di lire l'equivalente attuali di
circa 10 milioni di euro legge del film
commesso abbassava ovviamente calmierare
i prezzi
lo stato italiano cosa avrà risposto
sono bellissimo dibattito nel nostro
parlamento che dice la rinascita del
nostro stato deve partire da quello che
noi siamo rifiutano i 4 milioni perché
non si può lasciar partire neanche un
opera e quindi l'amor sacro amor profano
rimarrà lì dentro lo stato si tasserà
formidabilmente pur di riuscire a tenere
unita la galleria borghese
allora se pensate al concetto di
rinascita di rinascimento
siamo partiti di qua andiamo in un luogo
che è esattamente la metà dello spazio
in cui siamo qui sono 85 metri per 40 27
ad altezza
vi porto in un luogo che 40 metri di
lunghezza largo 17 e alto 22 è un luogo
che tutti conosciamo ogni giorno entrano
in questa cappella la cappella sistina
30.000 persone
pensate in una settimana tutta padova va
a vedere la sestina
allora guardate la sistina e la cappella
del papa sul fondo un altare sull'altare
domina il cristo giudice del giudizio
universale
ma c'è al di sopra se osservate una
figura che quasi il doppio del cristo
giudice è una figura enorme sono 4 metri
per 4 e quel fanciullo al centro che le
gambe un po larghi e ripreso dalla polo
del belvedere a sinistra c'è la
crocifissione di ama né a destra c'è
serpente di bronzo
allora quanti di questi 30.000 che
entrano il giorno della sistina sanno
perché quella è la focale della cappella
del papa perché
e l'immagine centrale di tutta questa
storia
giona e colui che è stato tre giorni
nella pancia della balena ed è quindi la
prefigurazione di cristo di queste
figure in fondo è quella che unisce
l'antico e il nuovo testamento è
l'essenza stessa della cristianità
eppure oggi facciamo fatica accoglierla
siamo rinati in altro modo abbiamo avuto
altri rinascimenti oggi per noi le icone
non sono il michelangelo sistina ma è
leonardo il vecchio leonardo che per noi
rappresenta il centro stesso del sapere
e della conoscenza l'uomo perfetto e
l'uomo completo
lo stiamo celebrando in queste settimane
nel suo anniversario
eppure leonardo in un signore
assolutamente inconcludente che non ha
mai combinato nulla nella sua vita ed
era considerato un artista ampiamente di
second'ordine al suo tempo tanto che il
più grande studioso di lenardo ster
kenneth clarke lo definisce in un modo
lapidario ed essenziale
leonardo è l'uomo più ostinatamente
curioso della storia ma accanto a
leonardo dovranno passare quasi 80 anni
perché si abbia un uomo che
effettivamente ha fatto della rinascita
del rinascimento la storia ce lo dice
ugo grozio il grande ugo grozio che
definisce quest'uomo la mente più grande
di tutti i tempi
chi è quest'uomo l'avete appena sentito
nominare
ed è un uomo che ha trovato qui 18 anni
migliori della società è un uomo che il
14 novembre del 1589 ci racconta
qualcosa di molto preciso e galileo
galilei e il giovane galileo che da pisa
arriva a padova ea padova
osservando col suo cannocchiale il cielo
dalla via di vigna è quella che
all'attuale via galileo in un
inizia a scoprire qualche cosa e
soprattutto cambia il paradigma della
storia perché galileo ci insegna
qualcosa che tutti dobbiamo continuare a
seguire per chi dice i suoi allievi
il metodo che seguiremo sarà quello di
far dipendere quello che si dice
da quello che si è detto senza mike
supporre come vero quello che si deve
piegare per conseguenza quelli che
imparano non sanno mai le cose dalle
loro cause ma la kg non solamente per
fede cioè perché le dette aristotele e
guardati come queste parole scorrono su
queste quereli sono neppure lì della
luna perché galileo con un occhio guarda
in alto e con i suoi acquerelli realizza
queste meravigliose opere e poi conclude
per conseguenza che una tesi sia
contraria all'opinione di molti non mi
importa affatto poiché corrisponde
all'esperienza e alla ragione che cosa
ci ha detto
galileo che li ho già detto che la
conoscenza non ha confini che dobbiamo
sempre andare avanti perché ogni epoca
di ogni generazione sono una rinascita
ogni epoca di ogni generazione sono un
rinascimento
grazie
[Applauso]